مجددا يدخل الى الماسك مالك منصه تويتر
الجدل السياسيه والاعلاميه الامريكي بقوه
هذه المره مع الاعلاميين الامريكيين بوجه
خاص التابعين لعدد من كبريات وسائل
الاعلام الى ماسك اوقف حسابات صحفيين
يعملون في شبكه سنان وصحيفه واشنطن بوست
ووسائل اعلام اخرى دون سابق انذار معتبرا
انهم تجاوز الحدود عندما تناول خبر تعليق
المنصه لحساب شخص ينشر معلومات عن مسار
طائره الى الماسك الخاصه
ومواقفه المتنوعه على مدى السنين الاخيره
دون مشاكل تذكر ولم يقف في الامر عند ردود
فعل الاعلاميين الامريكيين منذ الخميس بل
وصل الى اروقه الامم المتحده اذ لم يخفي
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الامين العام خلق
الامانه العامه من خطوه الى الماسك التي
اعتبرها سابقه خطيره من منصه تدعي على حد
قوله التمسك بحريته التعبير
التعسفي لحسابات الصحفيين على تويتر لا
ينبغي اسكاته اصوات وسائل الاعلام على
منصه تدعي انها مساحه لحريه التعبير من
وجهه نظرنا تشكل هذه الخطوه سابقه خطيره
في وقت يواجه فيه الصحفيون في جميع انحاء
العالم الرقابه والتهديدات الجسديه وحتى
اسوا من ذلك وما زلزلنا على اتصال مع
مسؤوليه تويتر
في قراره التعسفي حسب قولها واعتبرت
اللجنه انه اذا كان الامر يتعلق بالانتقام
من طرفه الى الماسك فان ذلك انتهاء كل
خطير لحريه الصحافه في نقل الاخبار دون
خوف من الانتقام
قرروا الى الماسك كبرره بالحفاظ على امنه
الشخصي والى ان تتضح اسباب اخرى لسيدافي
صحفينا امريكيين بعينهم فان الملك الجديد
لتويتر نجح في وقت وجيز مجددا في تاكيد
حضور ودور من السطح تويتر في مختلف
المحافل الامريكيه لاسيما الاعلاميه نصر
حسين الجزيره